[Musik]
je näher man zur Front kommt desto
schlimmer ist natürlich die Situation da
sind viele Leute eben auch auf
humanitäre Hilfe angewiesen dass sie
eben Essen bekommen und dort fällt wegen
der Angriffe auf die Infrastruktur eben
auch häufig die Heizung aus hier in Kiew
ist es soweit in Ordnung
hier ist es oft sehr sehr kalt sie sind
an der Front und dort gibt es ja
wirklich gerade massive Kämpfe viele
sagen aber sie sind dankbar dass ihre
Frauen oder Kinder in Deutschland sein
können
wegen der schlechten Situation diesem
Großangriff im dombaster ist die
Ungeduld natürlich groß jeder möchte
natürlich hier mehr Waffen haben um sich
während zu können auf der anderen Seite
gibt es hier eine große große
Dankbarkeit